i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas la guerra en ucrania
y las crecientes tensiones con rusia
siguen generando preocupación en los
países de la unión europea ante la
reducción en los flujos de gas natural
que llegan desde moscú y de los cuales
aún existe una amplia dependencia el más
afectado por este nuevo paradigma es sin
duda alemania un país que aún compra más
de un tercio de su suministro a los
rusos esta nación ha tomado medidas como
apagar la iluminación nocturna en más de
200 monumentos en berlín reducir el
consumo de agua caliente o la
climatización de las piscinas tras haber
reactivado varias plantas de carbón en
busca de fuentes de energía alemania
busca ahora también nuevos proveedores
siendo uno de ellos colombia el cuarto
exportador mundial de carbono una
práctica con graves consecuencias para
el medio ambiente y para los pobladores
locales el siguiente es un reportaje de
pascal mariani laura' chará y quan
orozco
es la mayor mina de carbón a cielo
abierto de américa latina' el cerrejón
en el noreste de colombia es operado por
la empresa suiza glencore y produce
altísimas cantidades de este combustible
fósil desde el año 1000 del 2021 de todo
se recompone 23.4
tras el embargo energético ruso alemania
planea comprar más carbón colombiano
katrin en berger diputada del partido
verde alemán se desplazó al lugar para
investigar las condiciones de esta
enorme producción
y toda la mina tiene un impacto
considerable en la región en términos de
suministro de agua potable pero también
en términos de contaminación del aire
sin embargo los representantes de la
empresa minera afirman que no hay ningún
impacto negativo en el medio ambiente
la empresa minera por supuesto me dice
que todo está perfecto y que lo tiene
bajo control pero durante nuestra visita
no hicieron explotación por lo que
intentan que todo quede perfecto pero
como soy una aficionada al tema conozco
la diferencia
la mina utiliza 24 millones de litros de
agua al día en parte para rociar las
carreteras y los envíos de carbón
sin embargo la guajira es una región
semidesértica donde el agua escasea
cerca del perímetro de cerrejón viven
comunidades indígenas wayú la empresa ha
desviado el curso de este río para
ampliar sus operaciones alterando el
ecosistema de la región
la que la empresa llegó al agua no falla
la comida nos va a cuánto muchachos no
se han muerto por falta del agua
y verdad hace que min y quizá me
sorprende mucho saber que las
comunidades siguen amenazadas de
desalojo tenemos que salir del carbón y
tenemos que hacerlo a nivel
internacional
luiz gustavo el nuevo presidente de
colombia gustavo petro está abogando por
una transición energética no obstante
necesita reponer las arcas del estado y
el embargo de la energía rusa representa
una ventaja para los países productores
como colombia por el momento el freno a
la minería del carbón no está en la
agenda en la ciudad de trípoli la más
pobre del líbano hay miles de edificios
en peligro de derrumbe ya sea porque se
construyeron hace mucho tiempo y no se
les ha dado el mantenimiento adecuado o
por la falta de un control serio por
parte del gobierno que ha permitido las
construcciones ilegales los habitantes
de los barrios en condiciones precarias
son conscientes del peligro de un
colapso de sus viviendas pero no tienen
más opción que permanecer en ellas el
siguiente es un informe de
abdelkáder vive con su familia en una
vivienda en riesgo de colapso el mes
pasado alcanzaron a recordar la escalera
para que no se hunda pero pasan las
noches en vilo y así vivimos gracias a
unos alemanes que vinieron y nos
pusieron estos andamios hemos podido
quedarnos pero hemos mandado a los niños
a casa de mi suegra no es seguro
susan otra vecina muestra la grieta en
la pared de su dormitorio que me queda
verse más puedo hacer el edificio
[Música]
mira este es por fuera le hemos mandado
el vídeo a la municipalidad pero no
hemos recibido ninguna respuesta tenemos
mucho miedo a que la gente
lamentablemente cada vez es más
frecuente este tipo de tragedias las
autoridades locales han reconocido que
hay más de 4.000 edificios en peligro de
colapso aquí en trípoli y
responsabilizan al gobierno central de
no haber tomado acción pero con un
estado en bancarrota
difícilmente el gobierno puede hacer
algo más que lamentar la próxima
tragedia durante años se ha permitido la
construcción ilegal según explica el
arquitecto base saudí el problema es que
muchos de los edificios abandonados
durante la guerra civil fueron ocupados
por familias pobres que han construido
legalmente encima se convierte en una
bomba de más ambos no podemos culpar a
la gente sin recursos porque quiera
tener una casa si el gobierno hubiera
puesto medidas evitarían muchas
tragedias
para khaled y su familia fue demasiado
tarde el 26 de junio el edificio en el
que vivían se derrumbó su hija y humana
acabó enterrada bajo los escombros rimas
tu esposa tiene ahora problemas de
movilidad viven en casa de su hermana
pero no hay día en el que no se lamente
por no haber podido protegerla nadie
dice lo siento rabia dolor no es justo y
humana murió porque el estado no
proporciona viviendas adecuadas a los
tripolitanos
la foto es humana cuelga junto al
edificio derrumbado como reformatorio
regresar al lugar de la tragedia no le
es fácil en medio de los escombros
hallett desde la resignación se pregunta
quién será el próximo en medio de una
crisis sociopolítica y de derechos
humanos que persiste desde el año 2018
en nicaragua las autoridades han
eliminado la personería jurídica de más
de 1000 organizaciones sin fines de
lucro varias han trasladado sus labores
al vecino costa rica nuestra
corresponsal cindy regidor nos cuenta
las historias de tres de ellas
la hermana paola salió expulsada por el
gobierno nicaragüense junto a sus 17
compañeras de la asociación misioneras
de la caridad ahora desde costa rica
hacen su labor social pero lamenta no
poder seguir ayudando a los más
desprotegidos en nicaragua dolor con
pena pero sabiendo pues que desde la fe
ve viendo que es la voluntad de dios no
entendemos por qué pero la voluntad de
dios siempre está ahí verdad las
autoridades en nicaragua anularon a más
de mil ongs de toda índole
inclusive universidades como la paulo
freire su rector considera que es una
represalia por su respaldo a
universitarios que protagonizaron
masivas protestas contra el gobierno
hace cuatro años desde san jose imparte
clases a nicaragüenses refugiados
tenemos
a contribuir
a que la generación de jóvenes que fue
pulsada el país se eduque el cierre de
organizaciones empezó en 2018 elvira
cuadra trabajaba en ese entonces para
dos centros de investigación social y
académica que fueron obligados a cerrar
sus puertas decidió fundar uno nuevo en
costa rica la investigadora considera
que la abolición de la sociedad civil es
un objetivo del presidente daniel ortega
mientras exista sociedad civil mientras
existan organizaciones sociales en
nicaragua
eso constituye un factor
que
contravienen su proyecto de estado
policial y de continuidad en el poder
la asamblea nicaragüense controlada por
el oficialismo justifica que las
organizaciones han incumplido las leyes
naciones unidas- rechaza el actuar del
gobierno de ortega y ha dicho que sin
espacio cívico no hay democracia
los incendios que afectaron a la
provincia de zamora al noroeste de
españa arrasaron con miles de hectáreas
este verano el fuego devastó un 40% de
una de las mayores reservas de lobos de
europa animales muertos pastos quemados
y cosechas perdidas dan muestras de los
daños incalculables para los pobladores
allí acusan a los políticos de abandono
mientras que poco a poco el lobo ibérico
comienza a regresar a su área habitual
de caza ahora quemada para alimentarse
de los ejemplares que no lograron
escapar a tiempo el siguiente es un
informe de nuria tesón
santiago el cabrero de san martín de
tábara lleva años denunciando el
abandono institucional de las
poblaciones rurales y el olvido de su
importancia para el cuidado del monte el
fuego parece darle la razón en cuestión
de minutos y el llevó todo por delante
un querido compañero pastor de ovejas
quedó abrazado por la liana una de las
cuadrillas forestales que murió el
hombre 64 mil hectáreas arrasadas en dos
incendios en zamora en el noroeste de
españa en las últimas semanas
en el primero ardieron 30.000 hectáreas
de la sierra de la culebra una de las
mayores reservas de lobos de europa aún
se lloraban las pérdidas cuando un nuevo
fuego devoró otras 30.000 hectáreas en
la misma zona en san martín de tábara
están las cabras de santiago y de sus
hijos muchos han quedado ciegas otras
están teniendo abortos la producción ha
bajado más del 50% la población local
culpa del desastre al abandono de las
zonas rurales que favorecen la
despoblación y ya una legislación en su
contra a los pocos guardias que hemos
quedado aquí nos han ignorado zamora es
parte de la denominada españa vaciada la
que dejan los jóvenes a no encontrar
oportunidades ni apoyos los hijos de
santiago se quedaron
con el beato de tábara una que sería
ecológica durante cinco años por
normativa no podemos postular en los
pastos que ya se han quemado el futuro
es incierto a la que sería se acercan
las autoridades para escuchar las
demandas de la población la principal es
que se declara el área zona catastrófica
concepto y no es de indemnización se
constituir de recuperación la obra
también decidió formar una familia en lo
que llama una simbiosis con el
ecosistema rural sus abejas y su futuro
se calcinaron en el incendio tanto a
ovejas y cabras y demás al final hacen
una limpieza en el ecosistema tremenda
de sus diez asentamientos de abejas el
fuego ha pasado por nueve todo lo que
hay en el suelo es la es la miel que no
hemos cosecha nosotros las tenemos que
sacar de aquí y donde las llevas si 30
kilómetros a la redonda está todo
quemado la miel del aura obtuvo un oro y
un platino en un concurso internacional
antes de esta catástrofe y no piensa
renunciar a lo que ha elegido como forma
de vida como santiago y sus hijos
considera que la supervivencia del pasa
por el apoyo a la vida rural y su propia
supervivencia
gracias por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en
fredes 24 millones 24 punto com
[Música]